Hãy chừng như run AMAZ ROGY, vừa tinh mẫu đợi ngủ thành sắp viên của các quan năng lượng
quên tự của tệ EIA. Hẹn chưa được phát tiếp cận, tuần bộ các cơ sở
hạm nhân của Evan theo thật thận vừa mới kì kết. Ông trở biết,
phạm vi giám sát sẽ được sát định chỗ các vòng đầm phản tiếp theo.
Những mạnh hiện tại chỉ có nhé mấy dự thật nghiên,
Bước Show, năm trong diện được tiếp cận theo hại trường AORG,
thật này phản lãi một khương khủ mới cho quan hệ Evan EIA.
Chúng đau sự hợp tác sẽ không còn giống chứ đây,
mà các liền với các điều kiện ngoại sao của Thay,
ông khẩn định Evan mong muốn tiến tớ sẻ tháng ngoại sao toàn dịt,
bối điều kiện các biên quan phạm tốt khăn kết.
Chứ đau tầm giống đau EIA, Raphane Grossi cho sang,
khung của tắc mới mọi người tất cả các cơ sở của Evan.
Kể cả các diện tương bị tấn tông và vật liệu hạm nhân hiện dịt tại đó,
sẽ khá biệt trong diện sạm của hai bên cho thấy tiến chiến đối thoại hạm nhân,
vẫn còn nhiều khoảng trống cần được làm sợ áo trong phvy ra tới.